what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
multiverse and i'm not sure if i told
you all yet but i am pretty excited for
spider-man no way home i guess i i
didn't cry during the trailer or
anything
okay oh my gosh i basically like
confirmed like freaking everything like
everything excuse me i'm sorry but
really are you even human if you didn't
feel something during that trailer i
think everybody is just super excited
for this movie now i don't think the
hype is gonna stop until we actually get
the movie and then probably for some
time after that as well and even if the
other two spider-man toby and andrew
don't actually appear but they will fans
would still be excited just at the fact
that the green goblin's returning doc
awk is returning electro sandman lizard
it's all just completely insane on its
own then you add the other two
spider-man in it and it's just bonkers
but today i want to talk about a little
rumor that could just take it over the
top and i do stress that right now this
is just a rumor it's not confirmed by
anybody but the rumor is that miles
morales could possibly show up in
spider-man no way home and if we take a
look at some things that have already
happened within the mcu it actually
makes a ton of sense and there's
actually a bunch of different ways that
they could introduce miles in spider-man
no way home so i'm gonna break down this
rumor and then i'll give you my thoughts
on it after because i i do have some
thoughts and of course if you love
marvel and want to stay up to date with
spider-man and the mcu be sure to
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so like i said the rumor is that
miles morales will show up in spider-man
no way home now this doesn't clarify
whether he's just going to be miles or
if he's actually going to be miles of
spider-man this is kind of like the
reports that matt murdock is going to be
in spider-man no way home but
daredevil's not just matt murdock just
him as a lawyer and it could be the same
case here it could just be miles morales
and not him a spider-man now i know
there are some people right now that are
probably saying well that's too many
spider-men to have in one movie and i
hear you but two things here one into
the spider-verse did it pretty dang well
and yes it was an animated film but i
actually think seeing that on screen
seeing all the different spider-men on
screen and spider-woman would be really
cool and two miles is actually the only
other spider-man that actually exists in
the current universe that tom holland
spider-man is in the other two
spider-man have to come from different
universes through the multiverse if you
don't know what i'm talking about let me
refresh your mind remember aaron davis
aka the prowler from spider-man
homecoming child just gambino popped up
and everybody was super freaking out
about it because it was super cool and
then he even said i have a nephew that
lives around here so the uncle of miles
morales mentioned his nephew which has
to be miles morales you don't have the
prowler in an actual spider-man film for
him to mention his nephew who is not
miles so therefore miles morales already
exists in the main mcu timeline the same
one that right now our tom hollands
peter parker exists in so if anything
the other spider-man are actually kind
of taking his glory in spotlight but now
we actually get more pointing to miles
morales appearance with the spider-man
no way home teaser trailer one
eagle-eyed fan in the trailer spotted
feast feast is a famous homeless shelter
in the marvel comics and it looks like
we do see spider-man peter parker
running through feast this homeless
shelter in the teaser trailer and
ironically enough in this shot he is
wearing a black suit which resembles
miles of suit just instead of gold like
peter's wearing miles has red perhaps if
this rumor does end up being a reality
maybe peter gives his suit to miles and
miles could change the gold to red now
we have actually seen other leaked
photos with feast trucks in them now why
is feast this homeless shelter such a
big deal and how is it related to miles
well for starters feast in the comics is
where aunt may works feast was created
owned and operated by martin lee in
which he recruited aunt mae to come and
work for him cool good for him but
somebody who volunteers there is miles
miles morales is an active volunteer at
the homeless shelter feast and if
everybody is about to forget that peter
parker is spider-man thanks to dr
strange's spell perhaps peter could get
a job at feast with his aunt may and the
next thing you know who is he meeting
miles morales so you can see all of the
connections of this rumor slash theory
miles already exists in the mcu he is
there they showed his uncle his uncle
mentioned his nephew which is miles
miles volunteers at feast feast has been
established we saw the leaked photos
before and in the trailer we see the
sign for feast and we see peter parker
run through feast without his mask on
and since he's wearing the black suit it
seems like this is probably after doctor
strange does his spell so there's a
possibility that peter could meet miles
after doctor strange does his spell to
where miles wouldn't know that he's
spider-man that would kind of suck
because we want miles to know that peter
is spider-man however since we see him
running through feast with his mask off
that's the perfect opportunity if miles
is around to see and know that peter is
indeed spider-man and hopefully if peter
is indeed working or at least
volunteering at feast and miles is too
hopefully the two of them become buds
and hopefully peter is somewhat
mentoring miles because there could be a
way in spider-man no way home for the
mantle of spider-man in this universe to
kind of go over to miles there is a
possibility that that's what our peter
parker wants mj is a very important
person in his life right now and as we
know spider-man at some points just
wants to have a normal life however with
great power comes great responsibility
and side note if we don't hear that from
toby maguire in spider-man no way home i
mean just huge missed opportunity but if
miles does indeed get introduced in no
way home that means they are definitely
setting him up to have somewhat of a
future if not that would be another
absolute waste to introduce him and not
do anything with him which i really
really don't think they do so there are
a couple of options for him to be set up
for the future one option is that
perhaps by the end of this film
everybody still doesn't know that peter
parker is spider-man this could give
peter like i said an opportunity to have
a normal life and after having a very
big multiversal run-in with other
villains from other different universes
perhaps our peter may want a little bit
of a break and if that is the case that
would make miles the perfect candidate
to take on the mantle this would also
give peter parker the opportunity to be
somewhat of a mentor to him because even
if miles took on the mantle peter isn't
going anywhere he's still always going
to be spider-man and there are
definitely going to be times where miles
is gonna need help in which i'm sure
peter would gladly step back in as long
as it wasn't revealed that peter parker
is actually spider-man but i personally
don't hope this happens i hope that
miles becomes a spider-man but besides
peter parker next to him yes i know
peter is going off into the college
years which is something we really
haven't seen before but i actually want
to see that i would love to see peter
parker try to go through college and
handle being spider-man at the same time
meanwhile mentoring another young
spider-man miles and in a way i kind of
think the spider-man franchise needs
this yes sony has their own spider-man
universe and yes they did rename the sp
umc the sony picture universe of marvel
characters thank goodness they renamed
this they have apparently changed it now
to sony's spider-man universe that's
very specific so clearly sony has plans
to introduce spider-man into venom
morbius spider-woman craven whatever
they have coming up in the future but
spider-man has to remain in the mcu as
well and i don't think these other
characters are going to be crossing over
into the mcu and when you have a movie
like spider-man no way home with all of
these villains and other spider-men in
the movie you have to figure out a way
to make it really exciting still moving
forward after the film because if i had
any concern at all for spider-man no way
home it's that they're not really going
to be able to top this moving forward
now kevin feige and the people over at
marvel studios are geniuses so i have no
doubt that they can but still there is a
concern of how and i think permanently
having two spider-man in the mcu peter
parker and miles would be really cool
peter in his college years and miles in
his high school years and i really do
hope that something like this gets set
up now if this rumor does end up being
true i don't think miles should make his
web slinging debut during this movie he
wouldn't get enough spotlight that
should be the movie after this movie
because i do think that would drive a
lot of the hype again should he be set
up in this movie should his character be
introduced absolutely i think they
really should do that but i think three
spider-man is enough for now but don't
get me wrong if they put more in i'm
gonna absolutely freak out and love it
the entire time but what do you think
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below do you think
they should introduce miles as himself
or as spider-man is that too much let me
know down below and don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to spider-man don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates of course you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you